like you know i talk about money and
happiness and there definitely is a
relationship between money and happiness
but it's a pretty small one uh so like
for example uh there's a study by
matthew killingsworth
doubling your income
consistently has about the effect same
effect on unhappiness so going from
forty thousand to eighty thousand
dollars a year
has the same effect of going from four
million to eight million dollars a year
has the same effect going from
you know like so basically you're in
this kind of treadmill where
uh you need to keep on
raising it by more and more to get a
happiness boost
uh
now of course
like
i sound like a conspiracy theorist and
these ideas are almost so cliche but
they're just true
you know advertisements don't want you
to think that money doesn't matter they
want you to think that you need
uh you know fan you know you need the
fanciest products and
uh so they're kind of
they're they're kind of telling you
brainwashing you a little bit uh on the
things that that will make you happy
that you know there are also been
studies that
uh the purchases that make people happy
and it's very rarely stuff it's usually
vacations travel uh gives the biggest
boost to happiness when you kind of ask
people what are you doing and and how
happy you are and and what what product
are you using uh the only products that
really are giving people happiness are
trips uh and
other experiences frequently with their
romantic partner or their friends like
museums tours
stuff like that yeah so so things like
that could legitimately give you a
heaviest boost they're usually not even
that expensive uh but when people are
using a fancy new electronic
uh or you know
wearing an armani suit uh they're not
really getting a big happiness boost so
i think that's an example why are we
wrong well
like armani probably spends more time
advertising than like that than uh the
grand canyon does
uh so
uh you know like yeah if you turn on the
tv you're not really seeing many
advertisements have you thought of
taking a camping trip in the grand
canyon with your friends uh because
grand canyon is a non-profit they're not
even making money uh so
uh it's it's it's they're they're yeah
so i think we're getting kind of
uh the wrong messages about uh the path
to happiness
what is it there was that famous study
that said above 70 000 a year money has
no impact on happiness it seems like
what you're saying here is that that's
[ __ ]
it's not true but it's
it's it's true in that
the effects level off a lot so it's not
literally true that you reach 75 000
then money doesn't improve things at all
uh but
going from
uh you know forty thousand to eighty
thousand is the same as going from
eighty thousand two hundred sixty
thousand so
it's it does it it is leveling off it's
just it doesn't level off to zero there
is also some evidence that like once you
reach about eight million dollars you
also get a boost
uh and i think the what's that
i think the reason for that is that
then you're reaching a point and i've
started since i moved to new york i've
met a lot of people
uh in that camp of eight million dollars
and well beyond
uh and i think they're at a level where
they
literally have everything taken care of
them for them and you see the happiness
activity chart uh that that included
don't trust your gut and like there are
all these miserable activities you know
standing on lines
uh work housework uh housework like they
really don't make people happy and when
you reach eight billion dollars uh net
worth or beyond you don't have to spend
much of your life doing those things
that's the point of which the driver or
the assistant can stand in line for you
when the chef can cook you breakfast
when the housekeeper can clean up blah
blah yeah and then you really can spend
most of your life just
by a beach having sex
in 80 degree weather what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you